ah, il a mon fils, votre clé pour le récupérer
[Applaudissements]
sérieusement, les promenades tombent du ciel
maintenant,
je décrirais la ville morte comme un nouveau type
de danger que nous sortons du bois
et pénétrons dans la ville de New York, ce qui est
vraiment  amusant, les éléments de béton froids
et le caractère inquiétant de l'architecture
et de la structure de New York sont une
énergie si puissante chez nous, c'est comme si, que faites-
vous lorsque vous emmenez les Walking
Dead dans une ville qui compte des millions et des
millions d'habitants, c'est un
spectacle complètement différent, c'est juste un tout nouveau
monde